what's going on reject nation greg and
joe where is your dark side i
screwed up i'm a bad fan always have
your
dark side only where ready dark side
should go for the rest of the week
god all right one shirt everywhere okay
let's move past this
i feel very i said let's move past it
this dark side teaser released online
i wasn't the impression it's a leaked
trailer so i told people like i'm not
gonna cover this because we got a
copyright strike on a godzilla versus
calm one that went up on a bunch of
trailer sites
and all those trailer sites and then
other reactors got copyright striked
because that apparently was leaked but
i've had a lot of people tell me this is
actually not an elite trailer that it
was an official
ad that played on twitch that was in
collaboration with hbo
like a lot of people were like no no
it's surreal so if we're gonna strike
it's not horrendous this is all
you guys all right if we get a strike
everyone who told us to cover it and it
would be okay us to subscribe to the
patreon
so we'll watch it and then we'll watch
it again right away
and then we'll talk about it
[Music]
whoa
wow
oh [ __ ] back
damn
[ __ ] oh
dude there's so much in here so bad
there's so much in here holy crap
that is menacing yo ray porter man i am
so
glad i'm so i'm so happy for ray porter
because that voice is sick
that is a sick ass voice and that whole
monologue
incredibly menacing you know like
steppenwolf is looking great in the
snyder cup but you know the second dark
side shows up and the
the various images you get from here i
think the beginning is that during the
the beginning the very first image is
that apocalypse
i mean but you like you see him with
assad and granny goodness
and looking at his contemplated manner
all i ask is that at some point when
darkseid is walking around he has his
hands behind his back
that's all i want at some point you know
and then you see here like you got flash
looking exactly like how we did when he
showed up
in batman v superman when he first
talked to bruce wayne
i think in this scene it looks like all
the people that are gathered here when
you slow this image down you have
joker deathstroke damn
that deathstroke looks so gritty this is
darkseid's trailer like i feel like some
of these images
are a little bit towards the end of the
movie is that darkseid's hand going on
superman's shoulder right there
oh yeah it totally is just this like
imposing
figure i wonder if in the that moment if
he's like succumbing to the anti-life
equation in that moment
was that part of the the plans for
justice league because yeah as we've
seen like the apocalyptic time
when he loses lowest he goes all dark
yeah that's what we were flash 42 in bvs
my mind's a little jumbled on some of
what we're supposed to know
or like where exactly this one's
supposed to end off on a cliffhanger
but if it ended on that note like oh
they get back superman they go through
all that work they defeat steppenwolf
but then he ends up succumbing at the
end to the anti-life equation for the
cliffhanger
maybe that's what could bring in uh the
martian hunter yes that's exactly
oh damn i'm not sure leave all your
thoughts or theories or
if you got your confirmed leaks yeah i
guess
there are people who seem to know
everything about what's supposed to
happen in this movie already but i even
love that shot with
superman doing his like optic blast on
all over steppenwolf right there
just like look how much pain he looks at
oh my god
every image of these characters here
just looks like a struggle like this
this is the version of like we're all
struggling against
about intensity and then cutting to the
apocalyptic
landscape late the of the future of what
happens if they fail
oh dude just the menacing desolate tones
that we're getting here you hear the
joker laugh at one point you get a
close-up on the joker card
and see some color on the joker you get
a little bit of green hair and red
lipstick yeah
clarify for me what the hell is exactly
happening here
guys at the end this looks like it's
probably from the ending moments it
could be i mean it seems like he's
writing a finishing move or something
like that i mean it seems like he's just
super omegaed up or something i think
zack snyder is getting us like
so pumped for darkseid and then when we
get that cliffhanger ending we're gonna
be demanding give
us the dark side justice league
the second movie plus two and three just
give it to us
give it to us damn it hbo they're doing
multiverses in marvel you can make this
happen
all of existence shall be mine oh
god where's tyra magnus to do the
impression i'm really regretting missing
that t-shirt right now it's what says
yeah man i screwed up man he's doing the
dark side he's doing the dark side of it
that's true
right she does it to like a whole planet
which yeah this trailer like it's cool
it's badass but it's also
just building so much menace and dread
in the way i think this movie always
wanted to not in like the dour un fun
way that it got
panned for doing and like really cut
down versions of snyder's vision like
when he can breathe
this stuff is super epic i mean i feel
like that
first battle sequence the one that was
kind of glossed over
in uh justice league one i think it's
gonna be
so freaking epic here i mean just with
the shots here you have of darks uh of
uxs at the time
just swinging around just sure
it's like it's like freaking sauron at
the beginning of the lord of the rings
this is probably like the best
comparison that i i think you you can
kind of give to it for that opening
battle is it feels like the beginning
prologue of uh the fellowship of the
ring yeah it looks like people are
uniting against this
one common enemy who seeks to conquer
the youth not just the world but the
universe yeah yeah it seems like a true
epic not just like oh big blockbuster
proportions but like a real
epic tale of battle and armies and all
that stuff
too he just looks so scary and i even
love that shot with a freaking aquaman
with his trident
yeah no everybody looks like really
awesome and also in the midst of doing
something of utmost
importance in this trailer and it was
cool to get that futuristic flash look
again absolutely
i kind of prefer it but i love all these
images
and i love the mood and the tone and
dark side definitely looks like scary
oh yeah especially in that ending shot
like oh that's a nightmare
in and of itself all right guys leave
your thoughts down below subscribe click
that notification bell hit that like
button last but not least
tyler hague listen listen dude if
there's anyone at our patreon page
that could be the next dark side oh yeah
it's you
you got the imposing presence right
away anywhere you show up you look like
you can murder someone yeah
but then you talk and then it's like oh
he's actually a really nice guy
hey greg and john how are you guys doing
well from existence shall be mine
yeah i'd be like oh man you look so
scary until you spoke you know
take existence did you take exactly what
i say
you want my wallet here you go man you
could be like darkseid's brother
who people are just not as scared of yes
or they're like oh my god tyler hey look
out for him and then they
he talks they're like hey i'm just as
evil as my brother
whatever man you used uh the anti-life
equation
on a little pandemic disease that you
got inflicted with then you destroyed it
obliterated
it it's going to cross its boat
i'm proud of you dude thank you so much
for being here for so long
and one day we will have a drink in
person love you buddy
[Music]